oh boy
shall I really name names I think you
should please okay this is going to be a
shocker Sally Field is a kiss and tell
kind of gal telling us all about her
worst on-screen kiss and guys she's
naming names hold on folks Burt Reynolds
the actress stopped by Watch What
Happens live with Andy Cohen on Thursday
a caller noted that Sally had once named
her Murphy's Romance co-star James
Garner as her best on-screen kiss but it
begs the question who was her worst
on-screen smooch this is going to be a
shocker hold on folks Burt Reynolds yeah
her real life ex Burt Reynolds I'm Yours
foreign
met her latex on the set of the 1977
flick Smokey and the Bandit the two had
a tumultuous on-off romance for five
years after they wrapped the movie
truthfully
I don't think she wants to marry me I
tried to look over you know over just
look the other way and say well that was
just then he you know it just was not
something he really did for you
isn't that something yeah he I could go
into detail but you don't want to hear
it I kind of do yeah
would not totally involved it's just a
lot of drooling but this isn't the first
time Sally has opened up about her
famous ex we've known each other about
three days four days at that point it
was instantaneous four days felt like uh
four years Bert often referred to Sally
as the love of his life you have said
recently that you still miss her
terribly she is the love of your life
yeah I do
I do miss her and shortly after he died
in 2018 Sally reflected on their
relationship during a chat with Diane
Sawyer I was always flattered when he
said that he um was a complicated man
she was recently asked for her reaction
to you saying that she's the love of
your life and that you miss her terribly
and she said I don't really have a
reaction right now but my reaction would
be for me to tell Bert have you reached
out to her I will know
Sally wrote about Bert in her 2018
Memoir in pieces and during a chat with
variety she admitted he was not good for
her in any way and following his death
Sally said she hadn't spoken to him in
decades I really didn't speak with him
for the last you know 30 years of his
life he was just a great gal and strong
strong woman
and uh and a brilliant actress now Sally
is lending her acting chops to an
upcoming collaboration with Jane Fonda
in the comedy 80 for Brady I could use a
little spice hi know her if you blackout
who you want me to call
an ambulance so I was there because Jane
has been one of my good friends in the
early 80s she literally knocked on my
door and said you know come on we're
going to lunch whether she's dishing out
the Deets this is going to be a shocker
hold on folks Burt Reynolds or slaying
on screen one thing's for sure Sally
knows how to keep us laughing
foreign